بعد موافقتي مجلس الوزراء السعودي على
قواعد المنظمه لشؤون العاملين في الاجهزه
العامه نشرت جريده ام القرى الرسميه احكام
العاملين في الدوله
وتعويضاتهم والتي منها اعداد نموذج عقد
عمل موحد للموظفين
السعوديه جريده ام القرى تنشر قواعد
واحكام شؤون العاملين في الدوله تضمنت
الاحكام ما يلي مراجعه سيعلم الرواتب
الوظيفيه بما يتوافق مع اسقف الاجور
المعتمده ومراجعه لوائح البدلات والمكافات
والمزايا الموظفين كما تضمرت حصره حالات
اصحاب الاجور والمزايا الماليه المتجاوزه
للسقوف القصوى ووضع معايير تصميم سلم
الرواتب الوظيفي واعداد السقوف الالزاميه
القصوى لاجور الفئات الوظيفيه اضافه الى
اعداد نموذج عقد العمل الموحد واعداد خطه
للقوى العامله
واعداد خطه للتوظيف تشمل اعداد الوظائف
واسمائها ومستوياتها المراد التوظيف عليها
سنويا
انضم الي هنا في الاستوديو عضو مجلس اداره
الجمعيه السعوديه للاداره بجامعه الملك
سعود الدكتور خليل ذيابي دكتور خليل حياك
الله فرشه الرابعه من الرياضيات احييك
احيي الساده المشاهدين
هذه القواعد الجديده ومن المشمول بها ايضا
اولا مرحبا بك استاذ نايف القواعد
لصدرت من مجلس الوزراء الاسبوع الماضي
وقرت في الصحيفه الرسميه امس في جريده ام
القرى هي مشمول فيها موظفين في الماده
الثالثه ذكرت فيها مشمول فيها موظفين
التابعين لوزاره الموارد البشريه اي اللي
يعملون على نظام العمل والعمال بمعنى انه
لا يتعلق بموظفي الخدمه المدنيه حاليا لا
يتعلق بموظفي الخدمه المدنيه احنا في
السابق
اقرت الدوله
الغاء وزاره الخدمه المدنيه وضمها الى
وزاره الموارد البشريه واصبحت هنا اصبح
هناك نظامين نظام الخدمه المدنيه ونظام
الموارد البشريه ومن ثم وقره برامج
الخصخصه والتحول اي الخصخصه والتحول في
المنظمات او الوزارات بشكل عام راح يكون
هناك
خصخصه من نظام الخدمه المدنيه الى نظام
العمل والعمال في الحالي لا يشمل الموظفين
المدنيه لكن مستقبلا عندما تتحول الجهات
والوزارات الى خصخصه راح موظفين للخدمه
المدنيه يشملهم هي الان تعني هذه القواعد
مراجحه مراجعه لوائح البدلات صحيح
والمكافات والمزايا للموظفين بمعنى سيعاد
النظر في فيما هو موجود الان وليس في شيء
يضاف اليها صحيح الان في الماده الرابعه
ذكرت في الماده الرابعه ذكرت انه انه يعاد
انظمه البدلات لجميع الرواتب والبدلات
والمزايا لجميع الموظفين الخاضعين لنظام
العمل والعمال اي نظام الخيط اي نظام
وزاره الموارد البشريه شبه الحكوميه شبه
الحكومه نعم باستثناء ست حالات وذكرت في
القرار الحاله الاولى
وكلاء الوزارات
والمساعدين لوكلاء الوزارات باستثناء
المزايا الماليه باستثناء المجال الماليه
اثنين بندل كفاءات المتميزه بنت التعاقد
على كفاءه المتميزه قبل سنه تقريبا صدر
قرار مجلس الوزراء باعاده ترتيب بند
الكفاءات المتميزه
وحدد بذلك وقلنا بذلك انه بندل كفاءه
تميزه بموافقه وزير الموارد البشريه وزير
الماليه يتعاقد عليه ايضا لا تشمل موظفي
بند الاجور ايضا لا تشمل موظفين موظفي
التشغيل الذاتي في المستشفيات جميع موظفي
التشغيل الذاتي في المستشفيات باستثناء
الاداريين السعوديين موظفين اللوائح
الصحيه غير السعوديين الموظفين غير
السعوديين على وظائف
ايضا في حصر حالات اصحاب الاجور والمزايا
الماليه المتجاوزه للسقوف القصوى ايش معنى
سقوف القصوى السقف الاعلى الحصر لجميع
الموظفين القرار اللي صدر انه وضع سلالم
رواتب وظيفيه لجميع الوزارات ورفعها
معايير تصميم صحيح ورفعها لوزاره الموارد
البشريه وتشكل
مجلس من وزاره الموارد البشريه ومجلس من
وزاره الماليه
لاعاده النظر في الهياء في
في في سلالم الرواتب وانها ما تتجاوز الحد
الاعلى للمنظمات
وراح يكون اعاده ترتيب احنا استاذ نايف في
علم الموارد البشريه هناك خمس تصنيفات
رئيسيه اولا لما تنشئ منظمه لابد انك تصمم
تصمم ماذا تصمم الوظيفه ومن ثم تحلل
الوظيفه من ثم تحلل الوظيفه ومن ثم توصف
الوظيفه ما هي اعمالها ادوار هذه الوظيفه
ومن ثم
تصنيف الوظائف حسب التضييع مثلا وظائف
القطاع الصحي وظائف القطاع التعليمي ومن
ثم تقييم الوظائف تقيمها هذا القرار بشكل
عام تقيم الوظائف تعطيها قيمه كم تستحق
هذه الوظيفه مرتب هذه اعاده
القرار ايضا جاء فيه
لو كان موسع فانا احاول اني اخذك قرار جدا
موسعه في اعداد نموذج عقد العمل الموحد
صحيح وش اللي يعني العقد العمل مثل العقود
القائمه في الشركات العقد العمل انه تكتب
اساسيات رئيسيه بالخطوط العريضه في عقود
العمل موحده على جميع الوزارات بمن ضمنها
الخطوط العريضه وضع الرواتب والبدلات
والمزايا ايضا من الخطوط العريضه وضع
الاجازات واستحقاقات الموظف
ايضا وضع ساعات العمل للموظف في الخطوط
العريضه وتكون موحده على جميع الوزارات ما
راح يكون في تفاوت في الرواتب بين
الموظفين
بالتاكيد راح يكون هناك تنظيم كامل لجميع
الوزارات حتى لا يكون هناك تفاوت باستثناء
السته النقاط اللي ذكرتها بالماده الرابعه
راح يكون هناك تنظيم على جميع الوزارات
وفق سلالم وظيفيه محدده جزيل الشكر انا ما
اتوقع عندي كثير من الوقت مستمتع بالحديث
الله
اكيد يعني شكرا جزيلا لعضو مجلس اداره
الجمعيه السعوديه للاداره والجماعه الملك
سعود الدكتور خليل ذيابي الله يحييك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات